so guys we all have our roles in the
family whether it's the peacemaker the
golden child the rebel you know the the
black sheep curious what your roles were
growing up I have always been the
peacemaker in my family yeah so I have
I've had to fly in and sit the family
down and say okay let's hear from this
side now this side gets us to act the
side gets a suite so I've always been
that the one in the middle so sort of um
cute yeah keeping peace it's interesting
I I'm my dad had a first marriage and he
had two two daughters from that and then
I'm my mother's only child and in a
second married so I I was always the
baby of the family
and I play this weird role or like with
my parents it was comfortable I wouldn't
say I wouldn't say very much because I
think we always have this weird
knowledge of what the other one was
thinking about them and my sisters would
come into the situation I would just
immediately be like silent and like not
know what to say and just like sit in
the corner and just you know really in
saying when I was one-on-one with my
sisters it was like amazing
it was beautiful I'm like they were like
half-brother half-sister a best friend
like it was perfect but for some reason
when everyone got in the room together I
just was terrified it was like everybody
else was taking up the room it was like
watching yeah I was watching and taking
notes
well the tagline or one of the tag lines
for cold turkey is something like
despite our best efforts we eventually
turn into our parents and you know in
this day of you know New Age and
self-help books and everybody's sort of
working on their inner selves how does
that still happen you know I think we've
all been there and then we catch
ourselves like oh my gosh that's what
so-and-so used to say yeah I mean self
helps okay but I think biology is a part
that hurtful I don't know I mean you
you're I think a your product of the
situation once you were raised but
you're it's brain chemistry like
you really do you your brain is this
incredible combination of your two
parents and you can't avoid that you
can't fake that you can't really undo
years and years of I mean I find my I'm
a parrot now and I find myself I said to
my daughter the other day you know I
don't want you up on the roof because I
don't feel like spending the day in an
emergency room so it's like not only am
I not saying I'm worried about your
safety it's really about I don't want to
sway my time in the emergency room I
remember with my mom when I was little I
was like that's so selfish of you you
don't want to spend the day in the
emergency room what about me I'd like to
be on the roof but now it's like flipped
and I understand it and it's it is a
long you know what I don't know how many
trips you've had to the emergency it's a
long day and it's inconvenient so I find
myself saying the same things that my
mom said
you